اليوم الذي يلي عيد الميلاد المجيد هو
اكثر الايام روجا يوم يعول عليه قطاع
التجزئه لانجاز اكبر قدر ممكن من المبيعات
بعد تخفيض البضائع الى نصف سعرها او حتى
اكثر فرصه للمتسوقين لشراء ما يحتاجون
باقل كلفه لكن موارده الماليه تحت ضغط
كبير في خضم اسوء غلاء معيشه تشهد البلاد
مما يحد من قدراتهم الشرائيه
بالتاكيد كان اللي غلاء المعيشه تاثير على
انفاق الجميع لقله مواردهم الماليه
[موسيقى]
لكنني لم اشترى كثيرا
المحل التجاريه مقتضه بالمتسوقين والشوارع
مزدحمه لكن الانفاق في هذا اليوم الذي
يعرف بيوم الصناديق او بوكسنج سيتراجعوا
بنحو مليار جنيه مقارنه بالعام الماضي
بحسب مركزي ابحاث البيع بالتجزئه ازمه
تكلفه المعيشه من جهه واضراب عمال سكك
الحديد من جهه ثانيه وراء انخفاضه مبيعات
في موسم جنون التسوق هذا
نقابه المضربين في قطاع السكك الحديد تدرك
مدى الاضطرابات التي خلفها وقف القطارات
في ايجاد وسيله اخرى لتنقل الركاب وتصر
على المضيء في اضرابها الى ان تستجيب
الحكومه لمطالبها برفع الاجور وحمايه
الوظائف
القطارات واخرين في سكك الحديد يحتاجون
الى مزيد من المال لمواجهه الغلاء
اكثر بقليل
اربعه مليار جنيه في هذا اليوم سينجز عبر
الانترنت لتوفير الوقت والمالي والتعب
التنقل وما تطمح اليه المحل التجاريه
بتقديم عروض مغريه لجذب المتسوقين اليها
لن تحققه في ظل نسبه تضخم تتجاوزه عشره في
المئه زادت من ارتفاع المعيشه دون رفع
الاجور يتماشى مع التحديات الاقتصاديه
مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن